david price is your starter tonight he
is your opener 1-0 the 395 era the
35-year-old left-hander
making his second start this year as an
olbert slater stands in
his eighth pitch slater strikes out
swinging were underway
took eight pitches but price
strikes out slater solano at 269.
no home runs he's knocked in four the
two two swung on and missed strike three
a terrific first inning for david price
he strikes out two
no runs no hits no errors nobody left
will go to the bottom of the first
giants nothing dodgers coming up former
dodger alex wood
who is five and one with a 193 era the
30 year old left-hander
in his first season with san francisco
and now chris taylor will come up
[Applause]
well he gets the strikeout anyway this
one's swinging
three up three down on both sides we go
to the second inning dickerson longoria
brandon crawford coming up it is nothing
nothing dickerson
had a double and a triple in the two
games in arizona
one two swung on and missed strike three
off speed breaking ball down and away
and the left-handed hitting dickerson is
down
on strikes three of the first four
batters that price has faced
he has struck him out two gone
and crawford coming up
the o2 swung on and missed strike three
how about david price tonight
six in a row and he struck out four no
score we go to the bottom of the second
and albert pujols at 198 six home runs
and
17 runs batted in
as pujols bangs one in the short left
field for a base hit
it kicks off the glove of crawford who
holds on his way to second base and he's
safe
stop the presses hold the phone
albert bullholtz legs out a double
and he's got a grin from ear to ear
and look at him stride it out
go mule go
austin barnes hitting 243 one home run
which he hit against the giants over the
weekend
3-2 pitch he struck him out swinging a
fastball away
strikeout number two for alex wood
two down and here comes sheldon noisy
slater is over toward right center the
pitch
hard slider down and in swung on and
missed he struck him out
to retire the side one hit and one left
we go to the
third inning now current casale will be
coming up
who's had a lot of success against david
price we'll see what he can do tonight
it is nothing nothing
is grounded to first in his first at-bat
and the one-two on the way swung on and
missed strike three
it wasn't pretty but vezia gets the job
done
no runs no hits two walks two left after
two and a half giants nothing in the
dodgers
so now turner with two out turner
hammers this ball
left center field it is gone
two-run home run justin turner
and the dodgers take a two to nothing
lead
two out thunder turner over the wall
now the fourth inning donovan solano
against alex vasilla
now the pitch to solano swinging a fly
ball
short center sprinting in dj peters
makes a sliding catch
for the first out of the fourth
meanwhile
here in l.a giants trailed two-nothing
longoria against joe kelly in the fourth
inning two outs nobody on
longoria hits a high drive to left
it is out of here
you got a hanging breaking ball and it's
two to one the dodgers lead
cut in half so longoria continues to
swing the bad well
his seventh home run of the year
2-1 as we go to the bottom of the fifth
and d.j peters gets set to lead it off
against alex wood
that is said well to left center field
d.j peters
a big league home run
[Applause]
living his dream dj peters is first
career major league home run
congratulations to d.j peterson
so here is donovan solano he has struck
out and flight out to shallow center
oh for 2 in the game the 1-1 pitch
fastball there's a drive in the left
field deep down the line way back they
are still going
donovan salado into the second row of
the
seats toward the left field corner has
tied the game
donnie barrels his first of the year
and it's all tied up here in the sixth
inning
nancy's grounded out twice against wood
now he's got a tie game again muncie
turns on a ball
sends it way up there and the homer fest
continues
badgers retake the lead
his 11th home run of the year the third
home run of the night for the dodgers
the fifth home run of the game between
these two teams
and the dodgers now lead 4-3 how did you
hit that one max did you hit it good
oh yeah he kind of shook his head though
i'm sorry
top of the order is steven duggar pinch
hitting
wow i mean
what are you going to do
looks like it's a wiffle ball oh my gosh
you're in the backyard playing with
somebody in your family and saying try
and hit this
mikey strips he's coming up he is
one for three the dodgers lead
four to three with two out nobody on in
the eighth
the o2 on the way here it comes and a
fly ball to right
bets racing on back on back and on the
warning track he'll make the catch and
that will end the inning
no runs no hits though there's nobody
left
you go to the bottom of the eighth
dodgers four giant three
so the giants down to their last down
it's longoria who has a home run tonight
high fly ball left center field no big
deal for
dj peters a one two three nine for
kenley jackson
dodgers four giants three
dodgers win the home run derby the
bullpen game
turns out to be a w they are now two and
two
in bullpen games